hello rejects its Greg Alba here we do
the best British accents ever sort of so
the BL BX creative grew a partnership
with Warner Brothers has sent over a
gift for a movie I'm gonna review this
weekend fantastic beasts and where to
find them now unlike Briana I've never
read a single Harry Potter book
technically fantastic beasts and where
to find them is a textbook required
reading for Harry Potter in book one yes
post Harry Potter saga
JK Rowling wrote the book by Newt
Scamander under the alias okay so she
wrote the textbook that Harry Potter
read in so you can't buy the book you
can you can buy wrote the book is a full
book if it was a textbook for okay yeah
okay you can buy it well maybe I will
disclaimer that I've already made
receive the products from Warner
Brothers thank you
well we open the box we don't know
what's in the box yet but here's what
the box looks like now
Brianna should know everything that's
belongs in this box I don't know a
single thing it's like it's like a
magical box like you know did you see
you saw the Harry Potter movies you know
how Hermione's bag is like an endless
bag like a Mary Poppins thing yes this
is like oh it's like that's amazing a
bottomless trunk it's real yes whoa and
I know it's possible to do that
that's incredible okay well Briana I'm
gonna give anything in here probably
everything to you cuz I'm that kind of a
human being because I'm so sentimental
for all this stuff in here I'm a real
sacrifice for you but
exciting I don't know if we're supposed
to pull these off hi well how else are
you supposed to get we're making a mess
Oh
front and back oh I think I'm broken I
don't think we know how to open boxes oh
well you have to take the box home like
okay so I'll start with the bottom
fantastic beasts coloring book
oh that is you're just the right age for
that Shh um have you not heard of the
adult coloring book fat the fat no okay
yeah so adult coloring books is like a
new thing right now because it is so
freakin calming if you haven't tried it
as a grownup you need to well that's
really nice game there is nothing more
calming as like coloring in say like
metric designs it's like amazing Wow fun
so this looks like it shows different
themes from the actual movie you could
color and Colin Farrell look at know
what since you're the one excited I'll
present to you oh look at this a little
bit of the political climate of
America's magic world America's future
wait Shaw America's future cuz they're
not well why you color in the wand when
you can have on yourself
Oh tell me this is not true you got to
take it out of the box take it out of
the box oh wow
whoa and it illuminates you can say
Lumos and and the the one tip will light
up oh my gosh oh my god that's pretty
cool actually gone hold on cool yeah
you're regretting say most Maxima no
what is this about everything with this
Wow are you put batteries in there of
basically a high-tech screw to unscrew
the battery case okay I'll do most
Maxima no I mean there's no batteries in
there though there are batteries
it's amazing was shipping and I would
love to get high and use that next time
you come up yeah it is I look like a
trip out you could do a whole light show
is this actually motion activated whoa
yeah how many spells do you now I know a
decent amount yeah and it also like
comes back to me as time goes on do five
right now Avada Kedavra I'm gonna do
that first
expelliarmus incendio a resto momento
that's when they're falling from
Gringotts and another one is Akio Akio
fan that's what the toilet is vlog yes
it's not yeah it is
Akio is when you need something to come
to you wow that is the most baller thing
ever
well what's more baller than a miniature
Danish girl
yeah the Danish girl no this is neut
different character david hockey
he's so wittle looking at you guys
he's so miniature I love him anything
else in here oh and you you travel a lot
I do this would be perfect for you when
you're on the road you want to keep your
team or something yeah Oh first of all
it's Turkish so it's double wallet so
it's insulated oh my god yes high
quality stuff and this says the magical
Congress of the United States of America
which is basically America's version of
the Ministry of Magic so freaking cool
well that's not all there's a whole
other side of this blog for when you're
reading your magical textbook okay and
here's when you write about your love
for me
it's a rule journal with a pocket know
what it means
casting her love spells all use of
strategies openness you may it's
impossible
what's the spell for open difficult
packages
that's the spell I need in my life yo
quiero el apoyo rip less packaging hey
duplicate scissors or something yeah I
got I got theirs I want to know what it
means with pocket compass oh yeah there
you go
yay oh my gosh phew house offices with a
pocket to hold your secrets ooh this is
your own personal chamber oh just in
time for the holidays um you know this
might be a little bit blasphemous for me
to wear as a ravenclaw but I accept the
fact that these are Hufflepuff
characters really cool yawning I'm sorry
why are you ravenclaw because who's the
Ravenclaw me I am
oh maybe she's reading cloth because you
know what I believe in going with the
house that fits you best
whether or not it's like glorified in
the books not everyone can be a
Gryffindor sorry you know what I mean
yeah yeah and like not everyone is
slithering cuz like just because you're
evil I don't know
ooh oh that's good on you thank you
I think yeah woman on TV full Harry
Potter doubt with my always shirt and my
Hufflepuff sweater huh well speaking of
shirt it looks like is it your size it
is not my size but that's okay a little
bit like an exaggerated Batman symbol
yeah
magical Congress of the United States
all right guys yep yep Briana
uh-huh uh-huh yeah yeah you did waiting
for Ted yes it's been going on for a
while when we cut the camera hashtag
fantastic beasts I'm gonna watch the
movie this week and I'm gonna give a
review of it not from a book source kind
of guy premiere are you going yeah you
are do you have tickets yes
Wow that's less loyal like what kind of
fan would I be if I did it well why are
you going to a midnight premiere I mean
they show like well subscribe to Brianna
White's Channel Brianna white sibling
gaming channel yes go to her gaming
channel a lot of fun stuff on there with
her awesome personality and you can
subscribe to the real rejects keep a
look out for my review and Thank You
Brianna here we go
subscribe to both our channels now you
must this is what conversations are like
with her when the camera's not rolling